foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the Pods at
Moving and Storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I am for
Ramsey personality and best-selling
author Rachel Cruz hosting this hour
with my good friend a vesseling author
Dr John deloney and we are here taking
your calls it's a free call anywhere in
the country at triple eight eight two
five five two two five so first up we
have Zach in Winston-Salem uh
where's
North Carolina I know but
oh hold on we got the the phones
hold on
all right Zach hold on Zach we're coming
to you we're coming to you yeah yeah
there you go thanks John
technology I was like look down that's
not right technology all right we're
back hey Zach how are you
I'm good how are you doing great how can
we help
yeah so I'll try to make this uh pretty
quick I'll just start by saying I should
listen to you guys like two years ago
when I called and I didn't
but that's water under the bridge so
um
I have been in baby step two
um for about two and a half years and
I'm almost to the end
um
looking like maybe october-ish I'll be
completely out of my debt about 20 000
left nice congratulations
yeah I'm not there yet but uh open to be
seen so my question is uh for the past
three years I've done two jobs I've been
in public education and I've also had a
job as a field inspector I have full
autonomy with that job so I sort of set
my own schedule
um but about six months ago that became
the primary source of income
and so I sort of had to pick one and
obviously I picked that one I've sort of
been looking for an exit from public
education for a while
um I've had my real estate license for
about a year and been doing that
part-time
and made the decision to replace public
education with real estate
um so this summer I'm making that
transition full-time
um I've had some success since I've gone
full time
um but still getting my feet under me
um don't really have a uh
idea of what it looks like and so my
question is when my school checks run
out because I'm 12 month employer I get
paid through September
um should I stop in stat cash
um who uh you know to build a buffer
until I know what that looks like or
shall I continue on uh and finish baby
step two
um well you have a job besides the
besides the real estate you have another
career that you're doing right
yes and yes and the margin with that is
about 500 to a 750 maybe a thousand and
a good month
um and so just not used to having margin
like that small and I just want to make
sure that I think you're going to tell
me to keep plowing through here
yeah I would I would so encourage you to
keep doing it I mean even if there's a
career change there for you and the
numbers you know even if they go down
and they dip down I would still stay the
track and I would honestly Zach I mean
if you can get this paid off by October
I mean that's just in a few months so
I'm like anything that you need to do
even if it's working extra for a month
you know at night or whatever it is just
to go ahead and get that knocked out
because once that's done then that 500
to a thousand dollars of margin that
you're getting that's going to be that's
gonna be all yours to then move on to
save up for an emergency fund and all
that so so yeah it's a small setback
once those checks run out from your
teaching but
um but I mean I would still yeah I would
still keep going forward
okay I probably would not have quit my
teaching job just yet but you've you've
already done that you've already
submitted your letter
yeah yeah and I didn't really have a
choice um I had to pick one or the other
uh I couldn't continue to perform
uh and keep the uh the other job and uh
and do that well enough to keep that job
so I had to pick one or the other okay
but you're getting paid through
September right so and you're gonna be
debt free in October so it's just one
month and I have made some money through
real estate um and hopefully that'll
pick up I don't feel comfortable saying
hey I can make this much money a month
in real estate yeah okay you're gonna
find out as a real estate agent
this is 24 7 365 those who make it
and very few make it so you I I would
recommend to do exactly what Rachel said
I'd start driving Uber at night and I
would take real estate calls as they
come in and as they come in in the
morning when I'm driving people to work
I mean I would do whatever I could that
the moment that this September check
comes through that's my last check to
pay off my debt and at least I don't owe
anybody anything as I roll into just
having one job and then a a business a
book of business I'm trying to build on
the real estate side yeah it's good all
right Zach thanks for the call up next
we have Mary in Chattanooga Tennessee
hey Mary welcome to the show
hello hello how can we help
well I just got a new job yesterday and
I'm needing to get a vehicle for it I
don't currently don't have a vehicle
um I'll be going from place to place
cleaning and stuff in the county and so
I'll need a vehicle for that I'm kind of
wondering uh maybe this step one how I
can cash flow a used new to me car yeah
great question well congrats on the job
that's exciting what's the job
um it's going to be cleaning I'll be
going around cleaning like after they
people go at apartments or they build
new apartments they come through and
paint and do all that stuff and then we
come in behind them get ready for the
tennis to move in very cool
so I'll be learning new skills and all
kinds of stuff excellent way to go good
for you Mary uh do you have any money
saved
no I do not I'm just starting on baby
step one I'm currently in an FPU class
and I'm just starting out on the big
step one so I haven't saved I'll have to
figure out how to cash flow this yeah
that's right our location's on the bus
lines I'm on the bus line but most are
not okay so yeah so do you um so you
have no other savings and what will you
be making in this job
how much a month it's it's going to be
part time and it kind of varies it's
almost like a commission thing and then
I'm a 1099 employee so I get paid like
it seems like if I'm getting the quote
is like 30 to 50 per job okay so and
what will you be doing
um
it like it's if that's part time how how
are you getting to a full-time work
um well that is the first thing I've
been able to get at this point
um I do are I do painting and artwork on
on as well as another side because these
are like two small you know side gigs
I'm doing right now concurrently awesome
this is a new one and I actually just
got a call today about another 40-hour
week job in addition to excellent good
Mary that's great Mary if you were my
friend or sister tell me if I'm wrong
Rachel I I would tell you
because let's say this let's say you
went and borrowed
um
three thousand dollars and you have to
pay that back and you're paying back 150
bucks a month let's just make up a
number
if you and your local community just
because you're going to do one to two of
these cleanings a day right
yes I would
I would Uber over there and it's gonna
cost you four or five bucks a trip and
if you add that up over the course of
your month because some days you won't
do any some days you'll do two maybe
even three if you if if you're able to
um I would not borrow money especially
this new into a part-time job I would
Uber over there and if I could take the
bus I would take the bus but if I could
Uber over there under the bus man
they're so unreliable when it comes to
like I gotta be there on a certain time
um but man I would Uber over there that
or Mary if there's people within this
um the same kind of industry if you will
that they're getting you from as a 1099
if there's somebody that you can partner
with and do the cleaning together and
say hey if it's a two-person job always
sign me up and see if that person if you
can at least meet that person right
maybe you can take the bus close to
their house like you can find a way to
eat carpool yeah
um that would be it but I would
definitely say don't don't take out
loans and it's going to be really
inconvenient for a season but save up
and pay cash for that next car but
congrat that's Mary I'm excited for you
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show if you
guys enjoy this show we just were
meeting some people in the lobby and
some of them were like we listen every
day so listen if you're someone that
that does that loves it will you please
help us spread the word and share the
show to people that you know send it to
your friends leave a review subscribe
just kind of engage with it because all
of that helps out in the world of the
internet to to get this message out more
because we want people to have hope in
all these different areas of their lives
and hopefully we can help guide them in
their story and in their process so uh
okay let's go to the phones again it's a
free call anywhere in the country at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and we have Anna in Huntsville
Alabama hey Anna welcome to the show
okay
um I was calling about graduate school
that where I start in the fall
um and I was wondering how y'all would
go about that what program
uh for physical therapy very cool
physical therapy is really expensive
isn't it
yes it is
how are you planning on paying yeah how
are you going to pay for it
yes so I am I applied for loans and I
did get approved for unsubsidized loans
and I'm sure you did I am new to all
this so I don't know much about it but I
was wondering if y'all would advise to
apply for direct Plus Loans so I would
tell you as somebody who took out six
figures from my graduate school loans
and was not able to fully take a breath
or exhale for years
can't in good conscience and I worked at
colleges for 20 years and I believe
deeply in college I am saving for my
kids to go to school I believe it is an
important part of a democracy I believe
in it and I can't good conscience tell
you to borrow 75 to 150 000 to get a PT
degree to come out making 75 grand which
is the last average I looked in that
particular career
um it's going to be brutal and so I
would tell you to
uh ask for to defer your enrollment and
get about saving money like like oh like
a wild woman and save and save and save
and save and pay cash for this thing
um I just can't get conscience recommend
it and by the way I've worked with
physical therapists who do this for a
career and like in coaching situations
and it's tough because they want to have
kids they want to start families and
they owe so much money when they get
done with these programs Yeah Anna how
much is tuition per semester
um for out of state it's about a hundred
okay first and then per semester
for three years and three years I am
trying to get in state right now since
we own property within the state so it'd
be 48k what is um 48 per year
for three years
48 for all three years or 48 per year
four or three years
three years okay okay that's that's more
I mean when you have a chance to cut
your bill in half
that's the smartest way so even if it's
deferring even if it's saying no to that
and applying to another College in your
state is it in Alabama
it is not okay just in Tennessee okay
but you have property in Tennessee so
you think you can get that and say I
would not
I would not do the hundred grand in a
yeah I don't pay I don't pay out of
state tuition but
many many many graduate programs will
waive that fee
um and I would save up and call a
counselor and say I'm gonna take a year
I'm gonna defer my enrollment for one
year I'm Gonna Save up fifty thousand
dollars I don't know how you do that I
don't know what your daytime job is but
I'm Gonna Save up that money and then
I'm good I've got fifty thousand dollars
to put down this program over three
years I need this to be in state tuition
and right now in many programs I don't
know the state of PT off top my head but
in many many programs what used to be
our parents and even me the
the applicants there's way more
applicants than there were seats in
these classes in many programs that has
flipped and there's way more empty seats
than there are applicants and so it they
make it feel it's artificially
constricted so there's going to be
programs you can get into please don't
get your heart set on a one program that
you have to do it and you're going to
pay double what what they're offering to
the guy sitting in the seat next to you
just don't do that don't do that don't
do that and please don't borrow money to
do it please take out cash because even
Anna when you look at the numbers of the
48 I'm like that's about eight grand a
semester
and and I was so what I would do and I
would even wait a year pause go work
somewhere go work in a physical therapy
clinic like go actually be part of it
because I think that is one of the
problems John that can happen is are you
just had you just graduated in May Anna
are you just going right into grad
school this fall
I I graduate in the fall and then start
in the fall okay I'm graduating
undergrad a year early okay okay so much
how much undergrad debt do you already
have
zero oh that's so great yeah and I
really would I would I would pause
for me if it were me go work somewhere
and even work in that field just to get
an idea of like hey this is what life
looks like day in and day out because
sometimes I don't know if you like this
John but you can like romanticize just
any career
education programs they get all the way
through until they do their student
teaching and they're like oh I hate this
but they're three and a half years in a
lot of programs have moved clinicals to
the very first thing you do is just for
that very reason yes yes so I mean
honestly Anna I in order for you to cash
flow this make it in state that in-state
tuition don't be don't be yeah like John
said so focused on this one program look
at options and take your time because
honestly this one decision with one
swipe of your signature
could determine your your whole future
and a level of stress of anxiety of
paying back debt and your career choices
have to make family choices in the
future I mean it's it's there's so much
there Anna and when you don't have loans
when you actually are slow and patient
through this process which is not fun
and exciting like I get it I get you're
probably very excited about this and you
think this is what you want to do and it
may end up being what you do
but taking time and having patience is
going to give you different options and
you're actually going to be able to to
go through this I really believe being
able to cash flow it so
um that that's our recommendation Anna
so thanks for calling uh it sounds like
you were a new listener so I appreciate
it but those loans that that had been
offered to you I would throw that in the
trash well and and one quick thing yeah
and that's Keith throw them in the trash
don't submit them back anywhere if
you've already applied for them
um
just before you defer tell the
admissions counselor tell them hey I at
the end of the day
um I've decided I can't in good
conscience take out student loans for
this program I really want to be a part
of it I'm willing to do a graduate
assistantship I'm willing to do work do
work study I'm willing to do anything
that y'all can provide that would allow
me to get this approach to to be a part
of this program
um but I got a cash flow and they may
just come up with extra scholarship
dollars because they're trying to make
their class there's a whole bunch of
other things that may happen that as
they're trying to shape this class so
it's worth asking yeah that's a good
point is communicate talk to them but
know this communicate
knowing you're in the driver's seat
you're not they make it feel like you're
like please please please I like that
old mervin's ad like open open it is not
the case they need you yeah they need
you yeah and so be confident when you
say hey I can't do it right now will you
please defer this or if we can figure
out a scholarship I'd be happy to come
so good so good well all right you guys
you know Anna is a new listener and so
many of you guys listen to the Ramsay
show even every single day and you know
the stuff that we teach but you may
still feel stressed out and stuck when
it comes to your money because here's a
video knowing what to do with your money
isn't the problem it's actually doing it
and Anna is a great example of this
right like you give her this information
it's like she knows what to do
but actually following through with it
and doing it is what's so important
because personal finance is 80 Behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge and so there
is a proven way to change your behavior
with money and that is by taking a
Financial Peace University class and
this class is different uh is the
difference between trying to get in
shape versus hiring a personal trainer I
mean you will have a coordinator with
you you will have a class around you for
the encouragement and people are such a
key part of change and so having that
Community what Financial Peace
University can provide is so key so
don't just listen to the show actually
commit yourself to doing something doing
a process to win so join an FPU class at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU again that's ramseysolutions.com FPU
we'll be back
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com ramsays
today to get three months of hallow for
free that's hollow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John deloney and we are taking your
calls so up next we have Nick in Austin
Texas hey Nick welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking the call
absolutely how can we help
so my business partner and I built a
spec house right outside of Austin and
it's currently listed on the market for
a million dollars and if we sell at that
price we'll profit 300 000. and from
that 300 000 we're going to cut
ourselves each a check of a hundred
thousand and then put the remaining
hundred thousand back into our business
account
and so I was just wondering how do you
what do you recommend for me to invest
that hundred thousand to start Building
Wealth
get out of this partnership ASM I was
going to say I wouldn't do the
partnership Nick yeah I wouldn't do that
but that's not why you're calling so go
for it Rachel like let me ask you this
how are you floating this note right now
because you got a 700 000 mortgage on
this thing how are y'all floating that
note
uh it's a construction loan and we're
paying it paying the interest basically
out of our own pockets what's that note
uh
five hundred thousand dollar
construction loan we're paying 10.9
interest
but what are you paying every month what
are y'all splitting
we're splitting about four thousand
so two grand where are you getting the
two grand
uh for my uh my regular job which I make
about 75 000 a year okay
wait there's no way that there's a 500
000 loan that's
four thousand you're putting in four and
he's putting in four
no he's putting in Louisiana too well
they're paying the interest it's just oh
just interesting okay so and you're
making a banker rich man you're hooking
them up
okay yeah it's our first one so we had
to bite the bullet on this High interest
not really but go ahead all right go
ahead
um okay so Nick where are you
financially what kind of debt do you
have I have no debt okay what except for
a half a million dollar mortgage of a
house you don't live in except for that
except for that okay uh Nick how much
money do you have in the bank
um I I have about fifty thousand dollars
in crypto and stocks and in the bank
ready to go I have about eight thousand
okay oh you're incredible you watch a
lot of Instagram don't you how old are
you Nick 27. awesome awesome okay here's
what I like about you Nick
you're running and got it like you're
doing stuff no it's a gangster dude he's
awesome yes okay
um can we just like give you like a
whole Money Makeover right now like if
we were to if John and I were to like
invade your home Nick and you were like
help me with every part of my money not
just what to do with this hundred
thousand but my life let me approach it
this way can we like to speak in and can
I ask it I'm gonna ask it this way okay
how long have you been has this house
been completed how long has the
construction been completed two months
two months okay
and if you're like me at all
you've long since spent this hundred
thousand dollars
and probably when y'all are fantasizing
about it it's gonna be 1.2 or 1.3 but
it's down to 100 Grand you long spent
since you've long since spent this money
in your mind and every month
your chest is getting a little bit
tighter and a little bit tighter and
you're starting to go
whoa right and so here's what we're
offering you
you've got your way bro you've got
crypto you've got the whole thing you
are doing like The Tick Tock Instagram
Playbook down to the like the T do we
have your permission to offer you just
another vision of what your life could
look like
you do all right let's do it amazing
okay so here's what I would do
now shot the 50
s the crypto and out of single stocks
and I would just put that in a brokerage
account just to have
um because we'll just we'll do some
stuff with that later with that 50 grams
I would add the 100 Grand to it so you
have 150 000
um of your money so I would not go back
into real estate deals like what you're
doing because it's very risky uh and
even though it seems like yeah it's a
done deal to John's point when you keep
taking on this risk and as the market
fluctuates if a buyer doesn't come if
your friend who I'm sure is a great
friend does something crazy and nutty
and all of this like I mean there's just
so much risk and what you're doing
especially if you continue down this
road you're it's gonna it's it there's a
there's a greed Nick that can start to
creep in where it's like oh I can get
that I'm gonna do that and you start
piling on this mindset that ends up like
coming into just a lot of risk and a lot
of debt so I would just stop that road
completely so after the sale of this get
everything get everything going and then
I would go back and say okay I'm making
75 grand I have a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars what's the wisest thing
for me to do I would take uh a chunk of
that because you have eight Grands just
in savings which I think is is plenty
for a three-month emergency fund or
you're single are you single yeah I have
a girlfriend but yeah awesome okay
perfect so yeah that eight grand can
just be in emergency funds kind of a
placeholder over here and then I would I
would invest this money Nick do you have
a primary residence do you own a home
I rent an apartment in Austin awesome
okay do you think Austin will be a
long-term place for you
yeah for at least the next five ten
years perfect okay so what I would do
Nick is I would buy real estate with
that hundred and fifty thousand dollars
uh and that's a that could be it
actually be 200 000 because I would not
put that other 100 into some
pseudo-joint business account that y'all
just gonna put down on another house so
take you split that up you each take 150
150 yeah wipe your forehead and Go whoo
we made it on this one we got real lucky
and then don't ever do speculative real
estate again yeah and I would do and I
would I would
do some of that
maybe 15 of that lump sum go ahead and
invest it do you have a 401k at work
I have a Roth IRA there you go perfect
yep I would go ahead and Max that out go
ahead and just put some money in that
for the year get that going and then use
the rest of this I mean I would look to
you know get a down payment on a home
because obviously you love real estate
Austin's a great Market I mean it's so
popular
um but I would find something you know
even if it's a town home for you that is
a 15-year fixed rate mortgage that's the
payments no more than 25 of your
take-home pay put a good down payment on
a home
um and start working to to pay that off
because what I want for you Nick when
you look up in five years
for your life to be yours not attached
to a business partner not attached to
um all this these real estate deals that
are out there and you're hoping are
going to sell and that it's going to end
up you know it's going to end up okay
because this deal did not every deal
does it hasn't yet but it might oh
that's true it hasn't even sold yet
um and I would and I would just be
investing and then on the side Nick once
your primary home is paid off then I
would say okay yeah you're a smart guy
so so start saving up some money on the
side and get you a small rental like go
go find a a condo or an apartment or
something something small to buy to dip
your toe in and actually own the real
estate instead of doing all this
flipping and new construction actually
own it get equity in it and and play the
real estate game that way versus what
you're doing is what I would do
personally let me tell you like in my
house this is me and my wife and my kids
I am I am right now putting money in a
money market account every month
I'm just hoarding cash in you know what
I'm waiting for I'm waiting for there to
be another dip in the market and I'm
gonna come buy your house for five
hundred thousand dollars
because you're gonna have to get out of
it at some point you can't keep robbing
Peter to pay Paul and there's going to
be a whole bunch of real estate across
this country in the exact situation you
and your partner are in where you had a
million dollar dream that turned into a
half a million dollar nightmare all you
do is pay an interest in this machine is
just growing and growing it's it's
getting heavier and heavier and so I'm
I'm just gonna wait until I can pay for
something with cash and so what we're
telling you is not something that we
just made up for fun this is how we live
our personal lives and I'm gonna buy
real estate at a discounted price with
cash that's going to be mine and nobody
can ever take it from me and I won't
care what the interest rates are I don't
care any about that crap and me and my
wife are going to sleep so well I'm
gonna be able to help somebody in my
community maybe even with a little bit
of a compressed rent because because I
can right because I own it it's mine and
so here's what we're trying to paint you
a picture of a non-anxious life man a
life where you can breathe and you can
go hang out in Austin which is one of
the greatest cities in America and you
can go have fun and you and your
girlfriend can go just go out and you
are not unable to breathe because every
time you look up and you're about to put
your debit card down for dinner you
think I gotta spend two thousand dollars
just to get the interest covered on this
thing I hope homeboy Pays His half
because he may not because he's been
screwing around with whatever you never
know man and so we're painting a picture
that's slow and boring and that will
make you a
multi-multi-millionaire over the Long
Haul yep low
low risk the long game
and autonomy owning your life Nick not
Distributing out to all these other
people so thanks for calling this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show so John
there was an article in Forbes
[Music]
um that I saw and it was talking about
before paying off all your debt consider
the downsides
the downsides of paying all of your debt
off so before I even read this I have to
say so in in my nerd World whenever
there's a study cited like a scientific
study the authors have to put their
conflicts of interest down there whose
funds their lab who where they receive
money from yeah just in case they're
writing a um a a research paper on how
good sugar is for you and they're
sponsored by like sugar American gummy
bears of America right and so they have
to they have to disclose that anytime I
see something like this I always have to
wonder like
who's who's whose author is behind this
because it's just just on its merits
it's silly but go ahead totally no
that's a great point it's a good point
okay so uh the article goes on that the
author is saying that they paid off uh
three hundred thousand dollars of debts
in their 30s which they were doing the
fire movement so the whole retire early
kind of movement so they basically lived
on nothing and put all their money to
pay off debt and to retire
so here are some of the downsides John
and some of these honestly I'm like yeah
this some of these make sense uh you may
have hiccups traveling internationally
so she gave up credit cards several
years ago uh and she said I saw a lot of
difference in my spending habits I
became a lot more intentional and spent
significantly less money overall by
getting rid of the cards and using debit
card and she said but some of the hotels
required a credit card for incidentals
and we had to negotiate using our debit
card one particular car rental business
in Italy required cards to have credit
limits that would cover up to the
insurance limit and our debit card did
not do that okay so but I want to stop
here this whole paragraph is all
positive if you ask me there's some
inconvenience but it's not a downside
it's not a downside right so I gave up
using credit cards and I started being
more intentional in spending less ta-da
that's what we tell people all the time
totally
um I stopped taking uh cash out all
right I mean it's like it's we started
tracking cash to stick to our budget
Tada a few hotels a few
we had to have an extra conversation
okay yeah right I you and I travel a lot
we both have to do that yes I'm
traveling internationally in a few weeks
um I had to my the person who's putting
together the travel for me I had my
debit card there to split the purchase
twice because there was a limit on that
debit card and we contacted the bank but
he had to run it twice and split it it
was a pain in the butt and but it was it
was an extra phone call for two yeah for
two minutes yeah that's it and the
rental car yep one particular rental car
company wouldn't rent and when I run
into that traveling so you find the
rental car companies that will and we
have two of those Winston I use we kind
of switch off yep and I literally use
those I looked at one in the Dallas
airport and I said please help me give
you my money and they were like well
it's 24 hours I said no listen I'm
trying to give you my money they didn't
want my business that's great and I
literally went to the next counter and I
said will you help me and they're like
oh my gosh they need a car in foreign
that's right that's right okay the next
one is your credit score may have
disappeared uh even with an extensive
credit history
[Music]
millions of American consumers
representing about 11 of all adults were
credit and visible meaning they didn't
have a credit score so she goes through
talking about that yeah if you don't
have a credit score you can run into
some issues
um just like taking out a mortgage which
is her next points but this is kind of
like saying um I don't want to get
married because I used to date a lot and
I was really good at dating and I don't
want to lose my reputation as a great
day right it's like when you get married
you're like that's not your identity
anymore and so when you're married to
credit scores yep as you're as the
metric for whether I'm financially
successful or not and the one that blew
my mind I say this all the time on the
show if I called the author of this
article and just gave her a million
dollars in cash it would not change her
credit score because it has nothing to
do with your wealth with how much money
you have nothing it has to do with how
much you can borrow how much based on
how much you've borrowed in the past
paying it back has nothing to do with
your financial situation that's right so
and the credit score will go down you
guys if you get out of debt just like
she experienced your credit score I
think it's on average 12 to 18 months it
basically just goes down down down down
down and disappears so if you're going
to get a mortgage which we'll talk about
that next because that's her next point
then yeah if you pull your credit score
for any reason it's not going to be
great as you're getting out of debt but
eventually it will become undetermined
meaning that you just they can't
determine a credit score because you
don't have credit history and here's
what it says for a while I just lived
without a credit score paying for
everything in cash and not having any
issues because my house was paid off and
I wasn't intending to move
and then look and then covet came and I
needed to make some drastic changes
awesome happened to millions and
millions of people and I need to get a
new home and sell the one I paid off and
that leads us to the next Point yep so
her next point of uh that a downside of
paying off all your debt is that if it's
harder to take out a loan particularly a
mortgage so we talk about this a lot on
the show we don't want you to have any
debt so you shouldn't be applying for
any kind of loan and not a personal loan
not a car loan no loan so there's no
reason to pull the credit score for a
loan now a mortgage is the one type of
debts we always say we won't yell at you
for but you can still get a mortgage
through manual underwriting okay so this
is where instead of pulling a credit
score and deciding dependent upon the
score can you get the loan or not they
actually look at you the person and you
have to be current on a job for two
years and current on all of your bills I
like to say for at least two years so
keep a record of your cell phone
payments uh cable internet electricity
like any type of bills that you have
monthly keep track of those if you know
in the future hey we're not gonna have a
credit score and we're going to want to
buy a home they're going to need are
kept
with your online profile of those
individual things right they keep on
let's look at arson we still get paper
well that's because you'll you'll hate
the environment it's fine it's fine why
do we still do we do we still get paper
we make our own butter so there we go
it's
2023. it's online so you can go back and
look at all your history online but yeah
getting a mortgage Yes again
inconvenient and we will we'll admit to
that all day long well I think George
said it was an extra an extra piece of
paper like it was an extra sheet he had
to fill out for him yeah I think so yeah
yeah um and here's again I always want
to look at these titles and then read
the actual article this is scientific
articles this is headlines because
before paying off all your debt consider
the downsides ultimately this section
the hardest thing right is about getting
a loan for a mortgage that's fair
it was really frustrating to explain my
situation that is not a downside America
that is simply a momentary inconvenience
and kind of a pain in the butt when all
these uh tv ads have you able to get a
mortgage on your cell phone you actually
had to tell the banker I need to do
manual unwrite underwriting because I'm
a millionaire I just don't owe anybody
any money I'd like to make a purchase
and they'll all go okay like send your
cell phone bill right I mean if if the
maximum downside in your life
is that you're really frustrated
explaining your situation you're doing
all right you're doing good you're doing
great that's a good answer good job
America all right and the last one this
is my favorite one oh geez ready you may
you may feel guilt spending money even
when you can afford it so
what a downside being debt free not
paying interest not owing anyone
anything having the freedom to make your
own decisions but man I feel guilty
every now and then about spending money
so I'm not laughing at the guilt I feel
this I came from a home that was highly
money insecure it was a time it was
tough I still to this day
have to Exhale I walked around Guitar
Center the other night budgeting like
ready to rock and roll and I couldn't do
it I couldn't do it I couldn't do it
until finally I did it right it was
tough I had that guilt is real that is
not a downside to paying off my debt
that is a built-in
trauma response that I have that me and
a counselor need to work out I don't
need to counsel people and and tell them
hey
don't don't get peace in your life
because you're going to feel weird about
it I need to go deal with my personal
feelings and so if this is you if you've
paid off everything and you realize it
didn't solve all your childhood wounds
it won't yep you gotta go do that work
such a good point and a lot of people
feel this you guys like that is
something we run into so if you're on
baby steps four and Beyond like force
yourself to spend and enjoy build that
muscle the practice there you go yeah
and practice it so that's awesome John
thanks for a great hour thanks to all
the guys in the booth and Emily shout
out to my my girl and thank you America
for listening we'll be back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of at Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I am Ramsay
personality Rachel Cruz hosting this
hour with Dr John deloney and we're
taking your calls Across America it's a
free call you guys so triple eight eight
two five five two two five and we will
be chatting about career relationships
your money anything and everything so
give us a call first up we have Chase in
Atlanta Georgia hey Chase welcome to the
show
hey thanks for having me absolutely how
can we help
um I'm curious if y'all have any advice
on making a career change while you're
trying to pay off debt
um just a little backstory about a
little less than a year ago I changed
careers to do something that I really
wanted to do uh something that I was
really passionate about but it was kind
of on a gamble of a part-time job that
would hopefully become full-time and it
has not become full-time yet
um and so my wife and I agreed that you
know it coming up on that year if it
wasn't full time I was gonna have to
figure figure out something full time
because we just need to be pulling in
more money yeah
um just so kind of just feeling a little
hopeless as that's coming up because
I've applied to a couple jobs and come
back my wife's been the provider mainly
you know I mean I'm working part-time so
she's been the provider for the past
year
um and just as a husband and as the you
know just spiritual head and everything
I want to be providing
um that's a really hard thing for me to
not have and so I'm kind of just unsure
of where to go
um yeah
I'll hop in and Rachel you hop in too is
that cool
um so first how old are you brother
I'm 26. okay so I want you I'm glad you
learned this lesson at 26. that's
awesome
um some of the stupidest wisdom of our
era our age that we live in is this
notion of Follow Your Passion
I'm just gonna go what the science tells
us is we become passionate about what
we're good at and what we're good at are
things that we have to practice over a
long period of time
and what that also tells me is if I get
a job as a podcaster or a YouTuber a
radio person like I have right now that
I wasn't particularly passionate about I
was really passionate about helping
people over time I've become super
passionate about this gig does that make
sense
and so it's finding out what's my role
what's my purpose but dude that can if I
got fired tomorrow if Dave just fired me
tomorrow and I was working at Burger
King this weekend I would want people to
have a little bit better day after
interacting with me than before right so
my my purpose for being alive would
still be intact it would just look very
different and I would I would I would
not be making as much money as I make
right now right so that's number one
number two
um I'm gonna challenge you to not
conflate leadership and head of
household with I make the most money I
think that's a dangerous path to go down
there's been seasons of my marriage when
my wife makes way more money than me and
it's been awesome because we're in this
thing together and there's been Seasons
when I make way more money than her and
it's awesome because we're in this thing
together but when you set yourself up as
I'm a failure or I am not doing X Y and
Z and so I'm not meeting some
I don't know I don't get started on that
road but you're not meeting some
standard that you've invented or
probably somebody invented it and handed
it to you that usually comes out and
guys making a lot of immature decisions
or being angry a lot or being ashamed a
lot and there's no sense in bringing
that into your marriage so be really
really grateful that you have a wife
that's kicking butt and keeping you all
afloat
I'm really proud of y'all for putting a
deadline on this thing putting it
putting a marker in the sand and saying
okay we're going to give this all we got
for a year and then we're gonna have to
Pivot and make another decision awesome
and you get to be really sad that didn't
work out that sucks you can grieve it
and be bummed out about it and then say
cool what comes next but it's not coming
next because here's what I think I think
you're adding those extra variables
those extra because I need to be this
and I gotta be this the extra pressure
because you're really sad that this
thing didn't work out is that fair
that is here I mean you hit the nail on
the head
um with the the anger and this and the
shame
um of everything yeah for guys and Chase
I I would tell you that and John you can
speak into this for all the work we've
done around specifically just like men
and women when it comes to money for men
money is more of a scorecard there is
something tied to like a guy's worth of
saying oh my gosh this is this is what
I'm bringing in this is where we are
financially like there's something tied
with a guy even different than a than a
woman
um it's like this identity piece and I
think whether it's been taught to you
like what John was saying or whatever it
is but like regardless of who you are
your net worth is not your self-worth
who chases the kind of husband you are
the kind of dad you might be or will be
in the future like who you are Chase and
loving your family and serving them and
doing what's best because what's what's
best right now is exactly what you're
doing of saying hey we've done this for
a year and it's not working I gotta go
find another job and it's not to fulfill
some role around that it's just to be
able to say yeah common sense is telling
us like I could be making more money
right now and yeah and and we're gonna
we're gonna decide that as a family so
um what's this passion job brother
uh graphic design
so if number one we're hiring so if you
want to submit your application for
graphic designers here go to ramsay.com
exactly right
um but two that sounds like one of those
jobs that you can do just absolutely
knock out of the park you can even work
from home in certain situations you can
do a great job continue to keep your
practice on the side and I don't see
this this dream as being dead at all I
see it being as not right now or I've
got to get some more skills under my
belt or I've got to learn the business
side of this thing and so working for an
agency or a company is going to be a way
I get a grasp on the business side of
this stuff
um like it just tells me that at 26 you
got a lot to learn and by the time
you're 36 dude it's it's lights out
that's a game changer so this thing
isn't over my brother not even a little
bit are you guys working the baby steps
chase you and your wife real trying to
pay off debt where are you guys at
financially
yes we're on baby step two we have about
30 000 in student loans right now and
that's it okay great how much have you
guys paid off so far
uh we paid we paid off about 10. nice
awesome well good well you're on you're
on the track so do this it's going to
sound cheesy but I'm going to tell you
but I want you to do it uh anyway is
that cool
yeah absolutely all right I want you and
your wife to hold a tiny little funeral
service
for this passion dream that you had
this I like it I'm gonna launch but
here's why it's gonna it might be silly
but I want you to go all in on it go all
in and invite friends if you've got them
that would be a part but kind of on the
inside joke of this whole thing but also
not really a joke here's what it's going
to give you it's going to give you and
your wife a marker
this is when this we we as a family
shifted we closed this door and we begin
opening other doors and that's a
powerful moment otherwise it just kind
of lingers and you take your new job but
you're still kind of checking your other
work email to see if clients come in and
you never fully go from one place to the
other you just kind of get Bill you're
everywhere so have a funeral for it say
we are done and we are now making this
transition and then take your wife out
to breakfast and I know we tell you in
baby step two don't do that but you're
making a major life transition take your
wife out to breakfast actually I don't
kick you while you're down but she'll be
taking you out to breakfast I know that
wasn't cool but it's true she can take
you out to breakfast and I want you all
to sit at the table and then dream
together okay what's our Sprint through
this last thirty thousand dollars we're
gonna take two jobs three jobs we're
gonna get this thing knocked out we're
gonna You're Gonna Stand Tall you're
gonna walk tall you're not gonna dump
the anger and shame onto her and you're
ready for this whole new transition stay
on the line we're gonna get you Ken
Coleman's get clear assessment I'm gonna
give it to you as our gift and it will
broaden your horizons and what you can
do with your graphic design dreams
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show so our
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
with 19th service Brands Nationwide you
can find Reliable help from great
locally owned businesses like airserv Mr
Appliance and Mr Handyman visit
neighborly.com today for help with just
about anything you need for your home
all right today's question comes from
Jonathan in Ohio my fiance and I have
completed the first four baby steps and
I have a question for you about number
five and number six I'm currently in
investing our extra money into mutual
funds and once the balance is above the
principal balance of our home I plan to
pay off the house why are you doing that
the current projection is the end of
2027. however we're about to get married
and we plan to have kids in the in the
near future should we be working on step
five now or waiting until we have our
first child to start saving for our kids
college I feel like we're out of sync
because we skipped baby step five I've
been watching your show for about six
months it's changed my financial mindset
thank you all right Jonathan I think
Jonathan does a lot of things out of
order
that's cool hey I do I do too man it's
all I get it I totally get it but yeah
okay so yeah you're skipping baby step
five you can't save in a college fund
for someone that doesn't exist yet so
yes you will be skipping that I would go
ahead and be putting this extra money
you have in a mutual fund that's
dedicated to payoff I'm going to put
that at the on the principle stop giving
the bank stop giving them vacation homes
to their Executives and their
shareholders by paying interest like
just stop stop pay the bank pay the bank
pay the bank put all that away and yeah
put that put that into the house and
make sure you guys if you're getting
married that you have you have money I
mean you're on babysites four five and
six so make sure you have money for a
great wedding a honeymoon like be
planning for that because there's
expenses coming down the road for all of
that and here's the hard truth um about
this about this question and I'll just
speak from my personal experience my
wife and I planned our life out and
we're both gonna go to grad school we go
to grad school then we're gonna start a
family and we were like time to start a
family yep and then year one went by
then year two went by the doctor's
visits then year three so I tell you
that just from personal experience that
don't put the cart before the horse on
this one when you have kids then you can
start an emergency fund I mean you start
a savings fund that's great I'd love to
see you Hammer through him just pay your
house off you're pretty damn close pay
your house off man
um and as y'all roll into after y'all
get married just pay your debts off pay
your house off but don't start
putting sit making savings accounts for
babies that aren't there yet yep just
not wise nope all right uh we're gonna
go to the phones again it's a free call
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five John and I will be chatting about
every part of your life so next up we
have Jose and Montecito California hey
Jose welcome to the show
hi guys how are you we're doing great
how can we help
so um kind of got myself into a little
bit of a predicament here I
I have I have a truck so it's an older
vehicle uh that I've been using uh to
commute back and forth from work well
however I was getting tired of paying so
much in gas and because you know in
California that gas is pretty expensive
over here
um
so I went and purchased a smaller
vehicle more economic uh
which was great
but I didn't really pay attention too
much to the uh interest rate afterwards
the vehicle the vehicle costs it out the
door was 19 000.
um
but afterwards when I looked at the
paperwork I have a 28 interest
whoa Amigo what are you doing oh no Jose
oh my gosh I secured the cleaners how
much did you owe on that truck
dude
with the truck do you still have it
okay so Jose what you're gonna do is I
would get out of this loan ASAP okay so
what you're gonna have to do is take a
smaller loan a two thousand dollar loan
for the difference to get out of the car
because you're upside down on it and I
would rather you owe two thousand
dollars with a loan from the bank not at
twenty eight percent go to a credit
union then have a car that's continuing
to depreciate the more you drive it
and it's this yeah I mean it's
astronomical interest rate so stupid so
I would get out of that today Jose I
really would and you'll get a loan for
two thousand dollars and I would drive
your paid off truck and not have
payments and start tackling this this
two grand I'd rather you owe two grand
than 28 grand and we say this right we
see this with love but we're kind of
clowning a little bit but basically
you're going to end up with about a two
thousand dollar stupid tax
okay yeah yeah unfortunately and then
you're gonna be like next time
somebody's like hey I got this good idea
you're gonna go no way man I remember
that by the way if the trade-in value
was 17 000 at this scam artist that sold
you this car that's a great point I bet
you could sell it for twenty thousand
dollars private sale and net a grand on
it yes that's a great Point Jose
yeah don't go back to them see if you
can private sell I would put this on
Facebook Marketplace tonight and see
what you can put it for 21 000 and see
what you get for it yep
is it a brand new car is it brand new it
it's a 2022 uh Chevy Spark okay yep I
would actually put it at 22 and
someone's gonna give you 20 thinking
they're they're getting a deal and
they'll just say how about just 20. and
then you go uh okay and then you're
gonna make a thousand bucks and you're
gonna have a thousand dollars for all
your indigestion and probably a little
bit of Preparation H and then you're all
done and you're never gonna do this
again right yeah no no lesson lesson
learned okay but it wasn't until
no I was gonna say that last piece of
advice that John said is so true that
I'm like this can make or break that two
grand loan or not actually coming out
ahead so remember there's all you're
always going to get a better deal most
of the time through a private sale when
you go to a dealership not as good and
especially if you're going back to the
people that sold it to you and you're
like please take it back they're like we
will for 17 because they know in their
heads yeah hey uh have you been through
financial peace brother
I actually just signed up to it um I
started on the sixth awesome good most
excellent all right here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna send you a free copy
of Total Money Makeover and I want you
to have that as just as your gift from
us and I want you to read that book as
you're entering into this class it's
going to be a great primer as you launch
into this class good for you man
awesome thank you so much guys and thank
you for your time
here thanks so you would be friends I'm
confident of it and you know what John I
thank you so much of all of this idea of
winning with money looking at your life
making different decisions there's a
level of humility that you have to be
like oh that was a stupid decision I
feel like we've had some callers call in
and we'll get off the call and we're
like we'll say to each other yeah
they're probably
not from them that's like no I got my
thing I'm gonna do my thing and they
keep running down that same track that
we're like warning warning warning don't
do it don't do it so there takes a level
of continuing to learn and to believe
that like okay not everything I thought
was correct is correct like I need to
learn something new and maybe the
decisions I've made with my money are
stupid and not good so I need to make
different decisions right like there's a
basic human element there that's really
key to change your behavior so there's
two things and I I'll keep in private
here between me and my counselor but
there's two things that have a struggle
with
for decades yeah for years yeah and
yesterday in my counseling session my
counselor's the greatest my therapist
the greatest she's incredible but she
says
how long
and I said what do you mean she said how
long are you going to keep working this
plan that has never worked at what point
and she used the word that I hate with
all my guts at what point are you gonna
submit to another way of of looking at
this problem yeah and that was the most
honest true thing I could have been told
the way I'm doing this isn't working so
we talked to a caller earlier that
um him and his buddy they created a
company and they built a house and now
they're having to float the note of
their private bank accounts interest
only because they had a scheme I think
and those dudes can't breathe
and it's it's like okay you tried it you
got crypto you got it's not working
will you be interested in trying
something else just a totally different
way of doing life and that's Jose's that
that's why I pointed all that out
because like he came with such like
humility this humility
so you guys sometimes it's just that
admitting I messed up it's my fault as
Taylor Swift would say hi it's me I'm
the problem it's me we'll be back
[Music]
thank you
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am at
Rachel Cruz with Dr John deloney taking
your calls but John you know what's
crazy is that the job market the economy
all of that it's kind of in a bit of a
funk right now uh and when that happens
a lot of people are looking for jobs and
new opportunities in other states
they're looking to move but that can be
really intimidating it can be exciting
you know there's a lot of emotions
around that but you can also take a lot
of the uncertainty out of the equation
when you partner with someone who's a
local expert and you're a new area so
someone that's going to show you the
best neighborhoods the most the best
schools everything around the city that
you're looking to move to have someone
who is there who is really good at what
they do and what I mean by that is a
really good real estate agent again not
all agents are going to do this but to
find somebody that really has their foot
in the market they know what's going on
and they're able to help guide you so if
you want an agent who will do all of
that then connect with a Ramsay trusted
real estate agent these are local
experts who go above and beyond to serve
you so you can trust them to guide you
throughout every step of your relocation
we can connect you with the Ramsay trust
and agents all over the country who are
ready to help you buy sell and hit the
ground running in your new home so to
find the best agents in your area go to
ramsaysolutions.com local agents that's
ramseysolutions.com local agents all
right up next we have Bernard in Detroit
Michigan hey Bernard welcome to the show
all right thanks for having me on how
are you today absolutely uh glad you're
here how can we help
well I just had a quick question
um regarding the
you know I always listen to the show and
you guys say like your home mortgage
should be 25 of your take-home pay on a
15-year fixed
um should that 25 include does that
include taxes and insurance yes yes it
does HOA fees anything and everything
gotcha okay yeah that was the quick the
question I had uh I have a home now but
thinking about like moving in the future
we just wanted to make sure I was like
setting myself up for success for that
move gotcha yeah that was a great
question and and I always tell people
you know that it's a conservative
percentage that we say and a lot of
people get mad at us because of this
formula but what we found is that when
you're when your home is not an
overwhelming part of your budget you
actually have margin to do other things
you have margin whether it's paying off
debt saving actually living life
enjoying life spending giving like
there's all this other stuff that you
want your money to do versus going all
to the mortgage so it really allows you
to have some margin in your budget
um so that 25 really allows I mean what
we believe your home to be a blessing
not a curse and that um you can there's
two levers you can pull there one is you
can have a massive down payment and get
more house right and then the other is
you can
make more money and they just depend
that sounds like the
um either or right but you can have a
great salary and just put down 10 or 20
and then do the 25 there or you can put
down 50 on a house and that's gonna
really drastically reduce what your
total is going to be your percentage
every month
that makes sense so
what what would you guys suggest if
because I know like you want to put
extra additional money towards the house
but if I want to move stay in like three
or four years should I still be putting
additional cash towards the house or
yeah I would because what you're doing
is just building an equity so when you
sell the house you're so you're going to
recoup that money and what we find too
is that sometimes when people have money
that they're like okay yeah I'm gonna
instead of paying down the house I'm
Gonna Save for a newer house you know in
two to three years
we find that life happens and sometimes
a vacation comes up but it's like well
we can kind of pull out of that account
or something else occurs you're like oh
I can take it out of here when you lock
it into your home and you're paying down
your mortgage you're getting equity and
it's doing what that extra money should
be doing and in my life if I go back
five years that is three jobs and two
states ago
and none of that was on the right none
of this is a good point how much life
changes in just those dudes like four to
five years man everything's gonna be
changing you're talking about we're
gonna do presidential election we're
gonna have new surprising findings
there's UFOs everywhere I mean you don't
ever know what's gonna happen man so I
would keep your foot on the gas doing
the right thing in front of you and when
you sell your house we'll get that money
back out
is that good Bernard sound good yeah
that's great thank you I appreciate you
having me off yeah you bet brother
absolutely up next we have George in
Austin Texas hey George welcome to the
show
hi Rachel hi Dr John good afternoon
what's up afternoon how can we help
so I uh by by your uh your words I would
be in baby step two but I've kind of
I kind of don't know what to do next so
uh I recently paid off my car
um had I found you guys a year and a
half ago this would have been a much
easier decision but I recently paid off
my car in about February awesome it was
way overpriced it took me
five out of the six years it was
supposed to take me at 600 a month I'm
not happy about it
um but I'm currently looking at seven
thousand dollars left in student loans
and three thousand dollars left in a
personal loan okay um I've been paying
my student loans throughout the entire
pandemic but I'm realizing that yeah
September once that interest hits uh I'm
gonna have to probably start paying the
interest on that as well and I'm
thinking is it a smart idea to sell my
car that I just paid off it's a 2017. uh
right now I'm looking at the kdb private
value is that twenty two thousand so I
could sell this car completely debt free
right now and then use the extra money
for a little beater for a while which
will be fine and I can just breathe easy
knowing that I don't have debt
but I I just don't know if that if
that's just a drastic decision to make
just because I've been listening to you
guys for a month now I'm just like oh my
God how I should just do this now or
yeah how much money do you make a uh
annually
uh when I bought the car I didn't make
enough but now I make 70. I made 70 for
the past couple years and how much do
you own student loans
yeah I have exactly seven thousand
dollars left so you'll have twelve
thousand if you sell this car for 22 you
have ten thousand dollars total of debts
personal loan student loans you'll have
twelve thousand left to buy a car I
would George George I would do this this
weekend I would do it because it's just
a car you know what I'm saying it's just
a car like it's not a house like
sometimes we we slow people down like
should I buy should I sell this house to
get out of debt all this we're like well
there's moving like there's so much
Logistics around buying a home and
moving all that a car is like
this this car you've got a you've got a
a negative relationship with this car
don't you
uh no no I mean I love my car
I hate my negative relationship with my
car now is based solely on the fact that
I've been listening to Rachel show and
George so and I found the money guys and
I found you and I found all this stuff
in the last month and I'm like oh my God
what I've been doing with my money for
the last however long is ridiculous it's
like you've been dating somebody and she
was kind of awesome and then an
ex-boyfriend came up and was like you
want to know something and you're like
no but you found out right yeah so hey
if I'm you I would sell that car this
week I just want to make sure I'm making
the right decisions yeah it's great
George because it's a car do you know
what I mean like at the end of the day
you can get a new one you can come back
to this type of car later like again
switching that stuff is it's pretty easy
hey can I say this dude I cannot tell
you George you are in the one percent of
the one percent nobody nobody kept
paying their student loans with with
when there was an interest pause for
three years so well done you are a hero
and here's the deal come September when
everyone's like we don't know what's
happening you're gonna go yeah I don't
care
and I'm debt free you have no worries so
keep that momentum going George I want
to take too much credit I will be honest
I I was dumb with that initial check but
it's fine
and George I would say this too if
you're doing the baby steps you'll have
that 12 000 left and I kind of
flippantly just say go get a 12 000 car
even get a six thousand dollar car and
take that another 6 000 for an emergency
fund if you don't have savings you know
like you can use all of this to really
fast forward this process for you so you
can actually start investing and
Building Wealth and doing the stuff
Rachel I might take one thousand dollars
and just Uber for the next two months
and buy a 25 000 car for 10 000 off
somebody who hasn't paid their student
loans and is not prepared for that
repayment to kick up get it George sell
it George congrats you're awesome thanks
for calling we'll be back
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
America's birthday well Rachel is
coming up the old Fourth of July you
guys big 4th of July people at the zoo
any house yeah we all live in the middle
of nowhere so you're like can you just
shoot right yeah I mean it's kind of
Fourth of July all the time at our house
yeah we're shooting fireworks all the
time I like it good we're going camping
and we're having a fire like always yeah
so good
um all right so here's what's crazy is
how much Americans will spend on
specifically fireworks for
this wonderful holiday so according as
my granddad said just lighting your
money on fire it says a lot not money on
fire uh so American consumers bought are
you ready for this
260.7 million pounds of fireworks in
2015. it's so many bombs in 2015 and it
was uh the most of any year between 2000
and 2019 but the pandemic changed
everything so in the 21st century
consumer fireworks Revenue slowly and
steadily ticked up from about 407
million in 2000 to 1 billion in 2019 and
then in 2021
2.2 billion dollars in fireworks that's
just a bunch of people sitting at home
so angry at their YouTube accounts and
listening to like Angry podcasts they're
like we're just gonna blow crap we're
just gonna blow everything up I'm gonna
blow it up okay so here's here's just
here's the math on 2.2 billion dollars
if you spent a thousand dollars a day it
would take you two thousand seven
hundred and forty years before you ran
out of money
um or if you had a billion dollars and
were told to spend it
um in a single year
you'd have to spend a minimum of 2.7
million dollars a day to reach Zero by
the end of the year this is so much I'm
so ignorant though to fire like I don't
even know we have fireworks at a park
right by our house so we just go up in
this hill in our neighborhood
sit in someone's front front yard and we
watch it and so like we don't do a ton
of fireworks because because we're like
in the city limb or I don't know like
it's illegal yeah yeah kind of it's
whatever so I don't even know how I mean
do they cost a lot like
yeah so give me like like the kind that
go up and it's purple and it like all
rains down like 10 to 20 minute show is
is it can be between two and seven
thousand dollars depending on zoning if
you're doing it in New York or downtown
LA I'm sure it's a million more dollars
okay um this calls them fireworks pyro
musicals
or is this like a whole other thing I I
honestly have never heard the phrase
fireworks pyro musical right that's like
when they do the music too shows at like
Disney World yeah
with the music so it's like and then
it's like did you say in sync on purpose
it's like instinct does a routine to a
fireworks show it's in it's in sync
um and then uh firework pyro musicals
cost one to two thousand dollars a
minute
good wait say that again one to two
thousand dollars a minute holy crap
exactly so
um anyway
it's it's a lot that's a lot of money
it's a lot of money no but how much do
you know John how much like if I went to
like a fireworks stand on the side of
the road and you bought one of those I
mean you could spend a couple hundred
bucks without without you no but like
what's one one would cost a hundred
bucks they're always like buy one get 14
free so but yeah if you went to buy just
one of the one that went yeah
yeah it can be up to 20 bucks oh twenty
dollars yeah um and then some of these
fountains like Roman candles Novelties
um like this
uh you know two to five hundred gram
cake repeaters Roman candles Novelties
The Fountains a package like that could
be 600 bucks well this yes yes
629.99 okay so you can go spend some
money yeah and you can't be the it's
kind of like Christmas like like Cousin
Eddie like you can't be the chump house
that's got lame fireworks if you're
allowed to do that in your community you
gotta go all out gotta like have them
listen some good stuff if you buy
fireworks on a credit card you can never
listen to the show again it's your band
from listening to the show you're off
don't light borrowed money on fire in
your front yard just like regular money
in your on fire just money you have
money you have oh God Bless the USA all
right up next we have Matthew and Tucson
Arizona Matthew welcome to the show
thank you thanks for taking my call I'm
actually going to read my message if I'm
a little nervous that's okay you got it
man do what you got to do all right so
I'm 28
um and I'm in the midst of a really
challenging divorce
um before we got married my wife brought
about thirty thousand dollars into the
marriage
um meanwhile I was carrying about forty
thousand dollars of debt
um we're now debt free
um as I work through that this
heartbreak my concern is for long-term
Financial stability and I'm
contemplating giving her above the 50 50
requirement that the law requires in
giving her money back to her
um is that a wise decision or does that
set me up for undue financial hardship
in the long run
um
when you say you're worried about her
long-term economic viability what does
that mean it's that here's what it
sounds like it sounds like she did
something and filed on you and you're
still worried about her or did you do
something and she filed on you
um I I had some moral challenges and she
has filed on me okay so are you doing
this as a
a way to kind of buy your way back into
her good graces or to prove to you like
I'm a good guy
um
I don't know I I wasn't planning on
telling her I was doing this
um I was just gonna do it in the end
I've had I've had friends that have just
when they head to the table they put 55
down on the table I've had friends do
that and it's less about because of this
future thing it was more to I want to go
above and beyond so that this is an easy
process and we don't go to war
if you're in already in the middle of
the war you have to know that she made
some choices some values-based choices
that she's not going to be in a
relationship in a covenant relationship
with somebody who did whatever it is you
did and so she chose to leave
and I'll applaud her for holding firm
and true to her values but anytime we do
that it comes with consequences as well
and you can't buy the your way out of
that if you want to help end this thing
and putting another five percent on the
table or whatever would help in this
thing I'm all for ending the War I I
just I hate how these things drag out it
just breaks my heart
um but I don't think you can buy your
way back into
I was I'm not such a bad guy I'm a
pretty good guy I I don't don't try to
buy your guilt
sure does that make sense does she how
is she when it comes to money Matthew is
there any part of you that's caretaking
her in the sense of like gosh she may
not be as fiscally responsible so I'm a
little worried I want to make sure she's
okay like is there any of that or is she
does she have a lot of discipline around
money
she's very disciplined around money so
it really is yeah yeah I'm very
discipline okay it sounds like you feel
like sick with your stomach and you
probably still really love and care
about this woman and this relationship's
over and there's just that that grief
and it's so hard to sit in grief and so
our bodies tell us to do do do something
do something do something do something
and this is a way that you can
you can manufacture action if you will
um and I would tell you that it probably
is not going to do anything other than
frustrate you in the long run unless it
does facilitate ending this contentious
divorce and just wrapping it up if it
was me personally
um I would put extra money on the table
to end the the transaction how long has
it been going on Matthew
um we've been separated for eight months
and I got served papers last Wednesday
oh wow so you're just getting you're
just getting going huh oh Matthew I'm so
sorry yeah
um in the service of the papers did it
have an offer in it
um from reading it with my lawyer
everything is 50 50. um at least the
what she's asking for right now
man I I wouldn't borrow any money but if
I'm you and I'm in that situation I
probably would put a little bit over
there's not I don't have a Rhyme or
Reason why I don't have like some
principle that I live by or something
other than
um
once you once somebody files for divorce
this is the relationship is over and we
are now in a business transaction and
anytime I do business deals I always
want to be extra generous and that's
just I do that with the lawn guy do that
with tipping at a taco stand I do that
just with every transaction I try to
engage in
um and so that's probably how I would do
that but again sorry Matthew you hired a
lawyer too yeah I hate that for you
thanks for calling you can't buy your
guilt yep well thank you guys so much uh
for listening thanks to all the guys and
Emily in the booth to make this show
work thank you John for a great hour and
thank you America we'll be back
thank you
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build well do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships I am Ramsey
personality Rachel Cruz hosting this
hour with Dr John deloney and we're
taking your calls it's a free call
anywhere in the country at triple eight
eight two five five two two five so
we're talking about again your careers
your relationships your money what just
the way you introduce the show it's like
you're trying to remember what my name
is
[Music]
called you by the wrong name so I do
have to remember your name John deloney
that's fair with Dr John
Dylan and I'm here with Rebecca Cruz and
we are taking your calls on life and
money I was Rhonda earlier we're excited
to have you glad you're here America all
right first up we have Heather in
Birmingham hey Heather welcome to the
show
hey Rachel and John how's it going
partying we are partying great how are
you
love it
um I'm doing great so my husband and I
were both 33 years old
um we're having a little disagreement on
how much to spend on our next house
purchase slash house and renovation
and I guess a little bit about us we
have 625
000 in cash and we make a little under
300 000 a year
uh we have two small children and
basically the disagreement is we started
off saying we want to pay cash but where
we are in Birmingham you know these
little fifteen hundred square foot tiny
homes are going for like over 400 a
square foot which I'm sure y'all have
seen that in Nashville a bunch and my
thought is why don't we get you know
15-year fixed mortgage paid off in two
three years whatever it is and be able
to buy a little bit more to last us
maybe 10 years instead of five years
whatever that may look like and I feel
like I've gotten him on board
um to get a mortgage but he wants to pay
it off in one year and I felt like the
big picture of this is all silly and
there's probably people listening to
this thinking laughing at our question
but no no not even a little bit more
jobs from you guys of like how we should
approach this because it's so different
because the 15 keeping a mortgage for 15
years is just not even on the table sure
yeah and I I would say your your
situation is better than most people who
call the show most people don't have 600
grand in cash plus uh more than a
quarter million dollar a year income
right so but the challenge y'all are
experiencing is universal
you want this he wants that and it comes
down to negotiating or navigating those
those Waters so that's Universal man so
no nobody's rolling their eyes at you or
if they are it's because they're jealous
yeah so and I don't think and Heather I
would I would encourage you guys you're
not too far off you're really close at
this point it's basically like do we pay
it off in a year or two years and you
could just split it down the middle and
say your app or you just pause and wait
a year save up cash and pay cash for it
you know so when you when he says I want
to pay it off in a year I'll do a
mortgage we're paying it off in a year
what's the difference in house between
one year payoff and a three-year payoff
well
I personally think we probably
need to get us to be in a house that's
going to last us at that 10-year Mark I
kind of think we need something more
like we can pay it off in maybe three
years like talk about like a hundred
thousand a year because he talks about
being wanting to be gazelle intense
about it but I'm like I don't feel like
we need to be in nor is that y'all's
teachings either it's not but I'll also
tell you I come from a history of
financial insecurity
and so whenever we got a mortgage we
didn't go babe gazelle intents but we my
wife and I did go faster than I would
normally recommend to another family
and so there is something important
about sitting down and getting to not
not spitting and throwing spit wads at
each other over one year three years
three years one year
but listening to him if he says hey it
it I can't I won't sleep for 36 months
knowing that one thing goes wrong at my
job and my family we can't make this
mortgage payment
and so there's something about that
inner Terror that interfere I that I
know that I live with
um and you on the other hand are saying
I don't want to be doing this again in
three years or five years when the kids
get bigger and a partridge in a pear
tree right so I think it's listening to
each other and then being really honest
about okay this is the house that we can
pay off in one year if we go gazelle
intense we pay it off in one year this
is the house we can afford here's what
it looks like here's the neighborhood
it's in if we paid off in three years
here's the neighborhood that it's in
here's the house that it's in and let's
just use real pictures in real numbers
and real data that way it takes it less
out of the Ethereal realm but I do want
you to have a heart-to-heart
conversation about how y'all
respond to the anxiety of owing somebody
money because it sounds like this is
entrenched in his like this was a goal
this was a goal this was a goal you got
it and now it's like ah let's buy
another house and get another mortgage
and that's just hard it's tough to
swallow Heather what's making you guys
move where are you now
um well we're currently in Birmingham in
a rental house and we moved uh we were
in Atlanta for almost a decade and then
we moved to Knoxville and then now we're
in Birmingham and it was for a job
relocation which that's the other part
of this is you know his income almost
doubled through this move so that's the
other part of the equation we have it
really seen before yeah that much income
so I would tell you that we
intentionally compressed what the house
we bought
because the Temptation is is not to let
your standard of living rise with every
new raise you get
and it continues to float and float and
Float now make no mistake you guys are
so far ahead of the curve you can do
whatever you want three years one year
five years you can do whatever you want
but there is something to be said for
having a little bit of discipline in
this moment when your life has
drastically changed and there's nothing
in the history you just told me that
suggests y'all will even be here 10 10
years
is there a chance of another relocation
Heather
not that I can foresee because it wasn't
so much a relocation with the same
company it was just a really great job
opportunity with a totally different
company oh okay I hear you yeah yeah
well I think what John said is important
Heather I would really
so get below the problem right get below
the one year the three year but like
what's going on in him what is what
what's hit what's driving his motivation
to get this paid off quickly and as a
wife like listen to that consider that
uh I would say on your end too still
speaking into the situation on what you
see and that you know that fear can
sometimes take over so much that he may
not even be able to see his way through
in your logic because you don't have
that you're able to actually pull the
numbers and say hey look we could
actually probably pay this off in in two
years and four months and you know like
you'll have a level of possibly a level
of logic that he may not be able to get
to because of his fear so like you guys
working as a team right so coming
together in it and it makes some people
hate the word compromise in marriage but
I just feel like sometimes it's what it
is and it's like all right let's meet in
the middle like together let's do this
but I would also encourage you guys
don't feel like you have to rush and buy
something renting is not bad so even if
you guys stay put for another year you
guys have been in three cities real
quick you didn't even get a raise cat
put that cash away and that may open up
more opportunities in the future so
thanks again for calling Heather
appreciate it and we'll be back
thank you
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
they're 100 percent satisfaction
guarantee and shipping is always free
see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
well the stock market has been all over
the place lately it's gone up it's gone
down back up again back down again and
if you're freaking out can I just tell
you don't the market dips
but it doesn't mean that you're going to
retire broke okay so you have to keep a
long-term perspective when it comes to
investing so if you just look at the
facts if you invest 100 a month from age
25 to age 65 you could have around 1
million dollars at retirement so it's
not that it's just too good to be true
this is based on a long-term average of
the return on the s p 500. and a huge
predictor of investing Success is Not
only the rate of return but that you
actually invest and you keep investing
consistently so no matter how old you
are no matter how much you're investing
intimidates you this whole idea of
investing you can invest with confidence
right now
and when you get a pro in your corner
they will be able to help you with all
of this stuff so you can connect to a
Smart Vester Pro they eat sleep and
breathe Investments this is like their
entire world and it'll take the time to
work with you and make sure that you
understand what you're investing in
which is a really key part of investing
you guys do not put your money in
something you don't understand and smart
investor Pros are able to walk with you
and teach you so go to
ramseysolutions.com
smartvestor to find a smart investor Pro
today that's ramseysolutions.com smart
Fester hey and I think it's important to
call out on these sometimes these ads
sound like we're just
trying to sell stuff right
Dave uses the smartvestor pro the cruise
has used the smartvester pro the
delonies use a Smart vessel report these
are things these are these are
professionals that we use in our own
homes to manage our family's legacy and
our money so yeah this isn't just like a
thing that we throw out there this is
what we all at trust our lives and our
money to as well yeah absolutely yeah
having people whenever it comes to any
type of money I say this a lot but it's
just true
when there are Niche parts of money that
can feel like oh my gosh it's like this
whole other set of skills and knowledge
and terms and words and all of it you
know so whether it's real estate or
taxes or investing or Insurance like
there's all these little buckets we have
people you guys that we recommend
because again there's such these Niche
parts and we want you to learn and
understand it but having someone that
does this day in and day out to guide
you and teach you like it's worth it it
is so worth it so again go to
ramseysolutions.com smartvester
right up next we have borche in Portland
Oregon hey borche welcome to the show
hey guys how's it going thanks for
taking my call absolutely how can we
help
yeah so um I was calling in because I
had a question for you guys I'm 32 years
old self-employed and I have an ambition
to retire in 10 to 12 years for the last
couple of years I've been investing
pretty aggressively 10 to 12 000 a month
my portfolio is roughly around 300 000
just a little bit over
um I don't have any debt I have about 90
000 in cash and uh you know the only
debt that I do have is a house payment
so I do have a college fund set up for
my children my child as well I have
another kid that's due here in a couple
of months so we're gonna bump that up a
little bit and my question was uh should
I start putting more money towards our
house to pay it off sooner or should I
continue to invest that 10 to 12 000 a
month uh in hopes of obviously being
done in about 10 or 12 years what's the
what's the Panic to to is it part of the
fire movement or like or like the great
uh Mr Money Mustache like what's what's
the what's this impetus to do this
yeah I mean I think for me it just I I a
couple years ago I just had a goal set
in mind I've always been a pretty
competitive person and I I've just kind
of set set my mind on being able to
satisfy you know ten thousand dollars
towards uh towards my Investment
Portfolio so it's more of just a goal
that I personally have I mean I love
what I do I don't see myself stopping
however I do just you know want to get
to a point where I don't have to worry
about uh you know how my business is
doing and uh you know have that peace of
mind I guess so I'd rather kind of float
into work right now and get it done as
quick as possible how much are you
making a year after that goal uh I'm
about 350 gross and about 200 in that
okay
um
well you know I mean we we talk about
investing about 15 of your income into
retirement so that's going to be
you know you're investing a lot yeah
basically like three months worth how
much you own your house
uh we own about 350 on our house uh
currently worth just over 600 000. I
mean we live definitely live well below
our means
um I guess the only only uh depth I do
have is I lease my car under my business
is 450 bucks a month uh but that's
that's about it so do you see would you
would you borrow
take a HELOC out on that three hundred
thousand dollars and put that in as a
part of your retirement scheme
yeah I've definitely considered it no I
was trying to tell you that's a dumb
thing to do don't do that
he's like maybe here's what I'm trying
to say yeah you've got money sitting in
account over here
on the roller coaster but you have this
steady drum beat that you are making
some mortgage company executive very
very wealthy
by paying them every month
and you're so over investing at this
stage you do have an incredible goal
dude I'm all about that goal that's
awesome but
um you are over investing while you
still have this massive liability over
here even if you say yeah but that one's
a 2.9 and a 2.4 and this one's going to
be I'm gonna make this one I get all the
math part I'm trying to give your your
little child and the new one coming what
you said something that was so important
I just don't want to worry about this
another word for that is peace
and when you have a house that is ours
that nobody could take away from
Portland can probably figure out a way
to take it from you but that Most states
that can't take it from you
um dude there's a whole other
it's a whole other level of Safety and
Security and peace in your home that you
don't even know yet either you got all
this money over here right
so yeah I would I would uh pay my house
off yep for sure I would pull back on
the investing I really appreciate all
the aggressiveness you know you're it's
like
120k a year that you're investing and it
needs to be more just like a 25 okay you
know so I would pull back and throw some
of that extra I really would because
you're gonna be fine like I understand
again you you want to retire but you're
33. you're okay and what John is saying
is so correct like when you have
autonomy over every part of your life
it's incredible it absolutely is
incredible and so not having a mortgage
not owing anyone anything there's no
risk so even if the business did you
know have a bad a bad few months or
something you don't have any bills when
you're when your house is paper you
don't have a mortgage so so I would pull
back on investing I would still invest I
would invest 15 of your income into
retirement is what we say of your
take-home pay so that's that 200 Grands
is what you're going to be looking at
um after because I would love for you to
do like a Roth IRA which is after tax
dollars I mean so looking into 401K Roth
IRA well you're self-employed so it may
be a sep but I would um yeah invest
still but pull way back and throw that
extra at the mortgage can I throw one
thing at you real quick
yeah of course all right this is from
the greatest of Pharrell and I'm taking
her analogy and I'm using it somewhere
in a different context okay
but here's here's the the basis of her
um here's what she says you could never
go sweep up all of the glass and steel
and Twisted Metal
on September 12th of the towers when
they fell
and rebuild those Towers using that
original stuff
The Towers fell and you have two options
when they when they fail just leave them
alone
let nature take them back over the next
couple of hundred or a thousand years or
get some professionals excavate this the
whole thing
get an architect build something that is
a monument to what was and something
that may be stronger and even arguably
more beautiful moving forward to the
future
and we're going to build with our eyes
moving forward here is where I want you
to take that analogy into your own life
as a single guy or a newlywed you had
some ambitious goals and you have come
hell or high water you've been getting
these things done in an incredible
fashion if you were here I would hug you
out of uh solidarity I think you're
amazing and then you had a kid
and now you have another kid coming and
so the life that was is now over I want
you to consider it's falling down and
you can't say okay but I'm gonna keep
this thing going even though I got a kid
here and another kid here what I want
you and your wife to do is I want you
all to set set some time aside and I
want y'all to create goals that might be
somewhat similar but goals for this next
phase because you've never been a couple
with two kids and you've never had
financial goals and two kids and I want
you to reevaluate where you're going and
how fast you're going to get there in
light of everything is different now and
this can be one of the most fun and
beautiful Adventures for a couple to
undertake if you have the right spirit
so reimagine what life's gonna look like
with this new one you make a whole bunch
of money you're in great shape
[Music]
thank you
well standing on the debt-free stage we
have Steve and Laura you guys welcome to
the show thank you thank you so you're
staying up there for one reason yeah a
really big reason a big reason you guys
are debt free where are you guys from uh
Kalamazoo Michigan awesome so great you
guys okay so how much debt have you paid
off had to write this down and how to
actually recalculated a bit but uh 265
901.72
whoa okay so what kind of debt was it uh
so it was 14 credit cards
14. a lot of a lot of
stuff happening there uh I purchased a
used car to get it out of a over mileage
car fleece okay um a camper loan a
broken HVAC another car replacement uh
student loans and our mortgage
oh you guys so you were normal you were
normal okay I don't know the bounds of
normal how long how long did it take you
guys on this journey it took us 49
months 49 months okay and how much were
you making during that time
um we started off about 1 24 124
000 and then we with all the extra work
we pulled in about 150 000 for the past
years wonderful wonderful you guys oh my
gosh how does it feel it's amazing it's
amazing like just you know when I hear
you talk about freedom and peace I heard
it for years and you know we've read it
in the books but like to feel it is just
it's just life-changing incredible okay
so what happened 49 months ago to start
you guys on this journey well uh
actually somewhat started before that
um
basically I gave my wife a promise when
we got married that I'd give her you
know security as well as Financial
stability and I failed on those
financial stability part um a lot of
comes from a little bit of my history
didn't grow up very wealthy or you know
a little bit less income than normal but
we made things uh work as much as
possible but the moment you know going
to college got financial aid had those
extra checks that came in and hey
there's extra money might as well start
you know using it so I started using
that and then got a job of course I
worked for Best Buy got a job love the
electronics my paycheck went back to
Best Buy
um so it just started accumulating over
and over and over and a lot of it I'd
say it came down to me just because I
wanted everything yeah didn't have
anything wanted everything and I
did my best to get everything yeah so
over time it was like me and my wife um
I'm going paycheck to paycheck and then
being like Oh you know I should get one
of these and all of a sudden be like hey
can we get one of these and she's like
well we can't we can't afford it we
don't have any money I'm like I just got
paid yesterday and I got paid this much
why can't I afford like a 25 thing she's
like it's all gone I'm like and we would
like scuffle a little bit uh verbally
about this and then one day it was just
like we had one of those I sat
downstairs and I was watching YouTube
and I was like you know that's it that
that enough is enough like Dave said it
just it was that snapping point and lo
and behold Dave's face was on like one
of the suggested videos I'm like so I
clicked on that and that was literally
three months of me watching Ramsay show
uh videos on YouTube just pulling in as
much information and research as
possible I'm like you know we should do
this and then my wife's like well funny
thing they're doing Financial Peace at
our church so we signed up uh met with
Jake who who I actually work with now we
actually co-hosted uh the last financial
piece uh last year oh wow wow and my
plan is to teach financial peace with
Jake as two separate groups uh for the
church as well that's amazing you guys
oh my gosh okay Laura during all of this
what are you what are you thinking you
just like find like we're on board we're
gonna we're gonna make progress in this
or did it take some convincing on your
end to start this process I mean I was
ready and I I trusted him he's been the
he's been the money guy you know the the
nerd alert guy yeah when we read about
the nerd and the free spirit we don't
really have a free spirit but we
definitely have a nerd so I you know I
trusted him in this process and
um so it was hard of course it was hard
I mean I'd love to travel we didn't take
big vacations we camped a bit with the
kids which was great yeah you know I
drove a really terrible car for a while
we still haven't my daughter drives it
because you know we're not paying on it
right it moves it's perfect for an 18
year old
um so it it was not easy but
um now I mean that every moment was
worth it because of the freedom and I
think the most important for me is this
Legacy that we're leaving for our kids
you know we started late we're 45 so we
started late in life we were 41 when we
started but she goes to college this
fall and we're cash flowing that oh wow
so so we're sending up our kids to not
have student loan debt to not to live
without credit cards you know they they
both have jobs even my 13 year old he
Scoops dog poop because he needs money
to spend and he knows he's not gonna get
it for free from us you got great
parents young man what was it like being
married
to a guy that was out of control
um you know I just kind of felt like I
was just hanging on you know I was
trying to pay the bills and all these
credit cards some were teeny some were
big but I was it was like it was just
treading water and and trying to hang on
to this Lifeboat to get us through and
um so it was hard it was really hard you
know in our marriage we struggled in our
marriage because of that because there
were arguments about money he didn't
really understand the finances because I
was in charge of it and
um and I was trying to hold on to it
really tight because it was I was afraid
um you know so when we became this team
this partnership and and the
communication opened up and and we
developed this trust about our money and
we were making these decisions together
so not only are we financially free but
our marriage is stronger than it ever
has been and you talked about Legacy
change we we often talked about Legacy
change here in the company financially
right you've changed your kids financial
future
but your kids also got a ringside seat
to watching Mom and Dad be absolute
gangsters and heal a marriage and do
hard things and say I submit to this
process what I'm doing is not working I
gotta do something else and we gotta
head to the basement and spend some time
on the tubes right we got to figure this
out but your kids got a ringside seed
into that and so the both of them are
gonna find themselves in situations
where they're over their head that's
part of growing up and now they're gonna
have oh wait a minute mom and dad gave
me a road map here we can do crazy hard
stuff we can figure this out which is
amazing I'm so proud of y'all it's part
of that Legacy you guys well done and
it's been such a journey years and years
and years of doing it yeah and now it's
done yes it's done have you got that
first paycheck that deposited and you
have no bills does it already come yes
and it's hard I mean we have these
habits where things are we hold things
really tight you know the budget it's
like we have a lot of conversations
about that like you know you you can buy
that six dollar coffee Laura it's okay
slow down Drew slow down that's awesome
oh you guys I'm so glad that y'all came
to Nashville and we get to be with you
in person and celebrate with you because
we're so so proud of you guys thank you
um man what an incredible story well we
have the live and give bundle over here
that we're gonna gift you guys thank you
as baby steps millionaires uh Total
Money Makeover Financial Peace
University everything you need but your
coordinating class so thank you for
doing that and spreading hope to others
you can give this away to somebody that
shows up to your class and can't afford
it you got them that's right absolutely
okay so before the scream your kids are
here so bring them on up and who what
are their names and ages so this is KSC
Cassie is 18 off to college this fall
and this is Drew Drew's 13th oh Cassie
and Drew I was I was you I was you at
your age with with parents busting it
and doing it and man what a what an
incredible gift that you you guys have
of parents so well done you guys as a
family all right we got Steve and Laura
from Kalamazoo and they paid off 266
thousand dollars and 49 months making
000 to a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars all right you guys count it down
let's hear your big debt free scream all
right here we go three three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
oh amazing well done incredible That's
it man uh mortgage and all you guys
mortgage and all so you all listening no
you can do it you just got to make the
decision and say hey am I gonna start
this process and they are living proof
that anyone can do it so well done we'll
be back
[Music]